hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the 1966 chess Olympia in
Havana Cuba it is Arturo Pomer Salamanca
versus Robert James Fisher and it is
truly a game between Giants as uh Fisher
of course you all know who Fisher is
this is already the 23 year old Fisher
Zone a monster at the chess board and
Arturo Paul Mar Salamanca his Spain's
first Grand Master was considered a
prodigy uh incredibly strong uh he even
received a lesson from uh with former
world champion Alexander aleckin when he
was 10 years old and he even outplayed
the leaking in a tournament game once he
didn't win he did achieve a winning
position in the end game but I didn't
defended vigorously and the the in the
end the game ended in a draw but
definitely a very very strong player so
uh as you guys have seen that a very
cool line of the benoni defense where
white gets that past the d-pawn but the
black is just in trouble here we we're
gonna see a different approach where are
white again gets the past D Pawn but uh
black is not in trouble so let's check
it out here Arturo opens with the Ponte
D4 they call him arturito when he was
younger Knight to F6 C4 we have C5
Fisher now goes for the uh been on the
defense D5 E6 and now Knight to C3 so
all very standard stuff like we've seen
in the previous video G6 with E4 and now
Pawn to D6 first we have Bishop to E2
Bishop to G7 and now advancing the F
Pawn as well preparing Pawn to E5 we
have Castles by Fisher and now Knight to
F3 preparing E5 it looks like you can
push E5 and I um I played a lot of
benoni some 10 years ago and I I was
always afraid in this position what if y
just pushes E5 but if you know what
what's happening then you don't have to
worry I'm just gonna show you so you
don't have to worry captures captures
You're Gonna Play Knight after D7 and
now there's just no good follow-up for
white okay if Ponte E6 you can just
catch after if captures on E6 and
there's no way white can recap with
white recaptures then Queen page for
check and already white is just lost you
have to play G3 now you play Bishop
captures with Chuck B captors Queen to
E4 you attack The Rook on H1 and it
doesn't matter if
um the the Knight is captured you're
just gonna recapture because you can
never play Knights to F3 because just
Rook captures on F3 the bishop is pinned
so the best way to play this is Pawn to
E7 then you give give up this pawn and
then black is just better this is uh
this is just winning for black so that's
why you don't play E5 right away you
prepare it Knight to F3 with Rook to E8
by Fisher and now comes Knight to D2 now
uh E5 definitely is a move and here you
can play it but um Arturo goes for
Knight dt2 if you're interested this is
the reason why characters captures and
now after Knight after D7 now it's
different now you can play E6 F captures
and E6 and now you just castle that's
the that's the big difference and the
black can never recapture here your king
is safe now everything is perfectly fine
the problem with capturing another Pawn
on D5 is Queen captures on D5 check King
a trade and now Knight G5 and black is
in huge trouble
Knight F6 check is coming and if you
play Knight to F6 or even better Knight
to the E5 to guard the F7 Square even
Queen characters on E5 is possible Rook
or even Bishop captures on E5 Knight F7
check uh re-forks the the queen now G7
uh King G7 now but even Bishop to H6
check first forces the king to a uh an
unpleasant Square Knight captures World
captures and Bishop to C for check and
look at White's position the bishop
paired The Rook is slicing all the way
here the Knight is coming to at um uh E4
then to G5 then to F7 this is this is
resigns for black so uh well well it is
possible to play E5 and the people do
play E5 is just uh it just wasn't
Arturo's move of choice so instead he
plays Knight back to D2 he guards the
pawn also a very well known move and now
Fisher plays Pawn to C4 not a popular
move today nowadays A6 and Knight to A6
are the main moves but Fisher goes Pawn
to C4 now he wants to play B5 and A6 and
you can can never capture these Pawns of
course you need the knights uh to guard
the E4 pawn and if you go for some like
Bishop captures and C4 then Knight the
A6 comes to C5 and then you have even
more pressure on this E4 pawn and if you
capture uh the Knight okay you double
black spawns but you have the standard
uh benko compensation where you will
have the incredible Bishop The Rook will
come to B8 you will completely control
the board you will have the bishop pair
this is uh this is better for black so
that's why after the C4 move by Fisher
we have Bishop to F3 and now we have
Knight B to D7
uh the the Knight cannot come to C5 and
it is not as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game Arturo goes castles
we have B5 by Fisher now again you can
never capture this Pawn now if the pawn
is captured Queen to B6 check just picks
up the Knight so King the H1 now
definitely threatening to win the pawn
and now just spawn to A6 and this is how
Fisher gets his expansion on the queen
side which is something you always want
to do but uh when you're actually
playing it's sometimes very hard to do
we have Ponte A4 going after B5 Rook to
B8 we have a trade here captures
captures and now Pawn to E5 and the
reason for this E5 uh uh burst of uh
emotions so to say it is that there's no
good good move here for white Fisher's
position is already uh so much better
that it's it's hard to to find the move
here uh you know that the Knight is
coming to C5 then it's controlling B3
then it can come to D3 then it puts even
more pressure on e4 so that's why uh
probably Arturo just launched forward
with the C5 with the captors and E5 now
Knight D to E4 uh Fisher trades once we
have cappers cap press Knight to F6 and
now Pawn to D6 and again white gets to
pass deep on against the benoni but
um uh sometimes it's just not as potent
so here we have Bishop to E6 Knight to
C5 now attacks the bishop and pawn to E4
attacks the bishop on F3 Knight has to
go back we have captures captures and
Bishop capture so giving back one Pawn
but now Queen to B6 and you're not
afraid of uh the d-pawn because you will
create a pass Pawn of your own on the
queen side here Arturo plays F5 it's a
very strong move as it ruins Fisher's
King side regardless of how official
recaptures with G captures and now
Bishop back to C2 and Now official might
even have to worry about some sort of an
attack going his way but with Queen to
D4 immediately offering a queen trade
Arturo declines the trade he goes after
Queen H 5 but Fisher forces a queen to
G4 we have Queen characters F captures
and now Bishop to G5 we have Bishop
captures on B2 uh he decided to give up
this Pawn for some for some activity
because with the bishop and C1 uh
there's just no good way to develop your
game so bishop captris and B2 was played
Rook 8 to D1 now preparing to advance
the pawn and also the bishop here just
guards the d8 square but Fisher has a
very cool way of dealing with this he
plays Pawn to B4 as one always should we
have Pawn to D7 now the d8 square like I
said is already covered but Fisher just
plays Rook e to d8 he says uh have the
Rook I'm just gonna enjoy my past pawns
and while you will have to capture The
Rook at some point there's no reason to
do it right away First bishop to A4 you
don't want your Bishop trapped by those
pawns B3 now Rook F the E1 and now King
to G7
really not a better move now uh because
you are threatening Bishop back to F6
which will prevent uh The Rook from cap
the Bishop from capturing the rook and
the eight so Bishop captures 78 Rook
captures and now Rook to D6 uh we have
Bishop back to F6 now the path is
cleared for the pawns to be pushed Rook
eat the D1 and now just Bishop to G5 uh
the if you play B2 then Bishop C2 it's
it's very annoying it's the link for
black but it's annoying so Fisher first
prepares it he plays Bishop to G5 we
have rooked the B6 putting the Rook
behind those pawns and now Pawn to H6 uh
we have rooked the C6 now
um again stopping upon the C3 and now
Rook to A8 and this is a beautiful move
by Fisher because there are ways to win
this but Rook to E8 is just the nicest
one with Bishop to B5 and now Bishop
captures on D7 all made possible by this
Rook day eight move because now you
can't capture the bishop because of a
Checkmate on A1 but it doesn't stop here
they respond to H4 which creates some
breathing room for the king and H2 and
also puts pressure on Fisher's Bishop on
G5 so what did Fisher had in mind here
Bishop captures on C6 Bishop captures on
C6 and now there are many ways to deal
with this position but one is just uh
instant resigns so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Fisher
while I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
who were able to do it congratulations
on always playing the absolute strongest
move uh when crushing your opponent in
an end game and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pawn
to C3 that's right you leave your Rook
hanging and you leave your Bishop
hanging and there's just uh nothing uh
nothing you can do here it's completely
lost uh here at the game continued H
characters on G5 but of course it
doesn't help if you capture The Rook
just Pawn the C2 the C1 square is
covered uh
it's all the same so age captures and G5
was attempted now comes spawn to C2 G
captures an H6 with check King to h8 and
it was in this position on the Move uh
41 that Arturo Pomer Salamanca resigned
to the game and a brilliant brilliant
victory for a 23 year old Bobby Fisher
in this wonderful line of the benoni
defense and here you resign because once
The Rook moves uh B2 comes and of course
two connected pass pawns on the seventh
or on the second rank are stronger than
a rook they are they're stronger than a
queen so
um and it it would just be pointless uh
so yeah I told you guys uh we would
enjoy another uh benoni game because
they're just so amazing I mean it's so
uh that that's why tal for example
started playing it he said that first
you have to give white some sort of an
imbalance uh where okay atal often give
material imbalance but you often have to
give your opponent positional imbalance
as well and Bobby Fischer also
understood this uh so you can later uh
you know achieve a better position and
start asserting your dominance uh sure
uh that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it and that it might inspire you
to play to play against the benoni and
play the benoni as such a wonderful
opening the Banco especially or like a
special line of the benoni but uh you
know the benoni itself also really
really wonderful so maybe maybe you'd uh
enjoy giving it a go uh so yeah I once
again hope you enjoyed that nice Fisher
game uh I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Otto and I would like
to thank Jill will deers Ryan Cavanaugh
Robin and an anonymous person for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day